first things first Indians we have
managed to fight back after I review
billion surprise toys
I gave it a zero they have been now if
only we can stop t-series I will spare
any Indian that joins my side which side
of history will you be on make your
choice before it's too late and smash
like on this video now to something
completely different
yay handshakes everybody how do they
work
I don't know clearly I'm not the person
to judge here okay maybe my track record
on handshakes isn't the most thoughtless
thing but that doesn't mean I don't have
the right to life and judge other people
failing at handshakes which is one of my
favorite hobbies so let's feel a little
better about how awkward I am by
watching other people being more awkward
yay
[Music]
you me or nobody is gonna hit as hard as
life but it ain't about how hard you hit
it's about how hard you can get hit they
keep moving forward how much you can
take
hey keep movin
that's how weird it is done
[Music]
he
alright enough okay my favorite thing
about eSports isn't how good they are at
video games
it's how bad they are and human
interactions because they're always
forced to put that on the test as well
any time they go against each other they
have to finish up with some form of
human interaction whether it's handshake
whether it's professed whether it's
high-five or hugging but rarely rarely
it ends well and it leaves us with an
infinite source of great cringe material
let's start up usually there's an
instigator there's a person that says
you to shake hands and they're not ready
they're not ready you always want to be
a bit of a handshake over the wet
definitely not over here in Australian
counts right why did you tell them do
handshakes this is really purely the
fault of the hosts how can he just
assume that they're not gonna mess that
up
bit of a handshake over the I don't even
understand what happened you know how do
you go from this step moving ah
oh wait this is this is an older but
it's a class
[Applause]
[Music]
just love how happy they are at the end
you know some things you just got to
work for they're the reward and payoff
is in there until you gun through the
pain and Jesus Christ was that painful I
[Music]
think the problem is there's no recovery
you mess up there's no recovery unless
you dab back flip or something I think
that's the only redeeming thing you can
do the cat's-eye oh my god I don't know
about this guy or orientation but Fergus
is openly homosexual okay so he's going
in for the clear handshake now let's see
where things go from there wait is this
Hagrid
why is Hagrid commenting over handshakes
for the clear handshake now let's see
where things go from there
look at this what a [ __ ]
oh my god that is a sir dude that is the
most fucked-up mix-up I've ever seen and
he was not even ready he was not even
ready
[Music]
Oh No what is happening oh he's always
really thinking about it okay they find
it they find it no no no you don't
deserve that ground that's the king of
cringe crown I feel bad though cuz he
tried to make it smooth you know that's
the thing can we just not touch each
other all right this was literally
yesterday I think 3rd of September yeah
it was literally yesterday fortnight
summer
best of luck Margo's we'll see you in
the upcoming games fresh cream Lupo he
might be doing well with in-game apparel
he still needs to learn and I kept loop
I'm soon as he failed he just is like no
[Music]
pick one and commit ok
if you gotta do the brofist do the damn
bro fixed I don't even understand how
you mess up a brofist by the way ok it's
nearly impossible all you gotta do is
this there's no how hard do I squeeze
let it be known by the way I have an
amazing handshake ok
well no one asked you don't even have
hands people try now when they meet me
they're like can I please shake your
hand and I'm like yeah you can't you
know why this is amazing there was one
little King kid in Japan I remember he
tried he tried to trick me that little
Japanese son of a gun
try to trick me I'm gonna find it where
is it this thing's really good grinds my
gears oh yeah
[Laughter]
I just met Peter pie and he gave me a
proper handshake that happened come on
[Music]
yeah I found it look at this look at
this guy freaking me out
he tried they're filming I bet he's
telling his friend like alright we're
gonna get him we're gonna get him now we
fight this is our chance like I'm crazy
there goes by okay they knew they'd set
this up alright I'll film I'll mess up
the handshake no perfect you see that
perfect even though he faked me out I
recovered forget the handshake awkward
hugs is where a nice please don't do
this to me stop just stop stop oh there
it is
[Music]
I didn't even know I didn't even know I
thought he meant I should sit down oh
yes that's what you get Conan that's
what you get that's what you get for
messing up my life that's what you get
for ruining my life I'm shaking
I've never been this upset in my life my
mouth is elaborating we got a little
sidetracked let's keep watching
[Music]
let me explain what happened here this
guy most likely I'm not saying I'm too
speculative most likely he has some form
of phobia and he doesn't like touching
people
hence the posture of that you don't
reason I know this is cuz I I met a fan
and I was gonna shake his hand all right
this is not a handshake fail by the way
it was a handshake wing but I didn't
realize he had some form of phobia cuz
he was wearing gloves
it was clear afterwards cuz my saw it
and she told me and she was like he
didn't want to shake your hand cuz he
has the phone we have touching people or
something like that didn't you see it
was wearing blobs and I was like oh yeah
that's right oh I remember he didn't
want me to take his phone
now I remember that's what I it wasn't
high J Pam told you I told you I'm so
passionate about this subject hey I love
this clip and I'll tell you why cuz he
just makes a list like a UH hand gesture
it wasn't a handshake gesture so the guy
gets confused and he's like okay thumbs
up to this guy and then he gets confused
and he's like oh do you want to shake my
hand oh wait what but this guy on the
left absolute legend because as this guy
points out he obviously gets a kick out
of awkward this was you know it fuels
some people it gives him strength
it's a buff for him I bet he played
better after this cuz he just dominated
this guy oh oh this guy is like why are
you touching me like he's rubbing his
hands like I need I need at least
someone to touch him
I just need to get rid of this crane
please it's a tough life to live I get
it we're all gonna die and here we are
just we can't even touch each other you
see an untrained eye my hat might have
missed that one
I bet an expert level five handshake
failed trans compilation guy spotted
immediately here you see he goes in and
they kind of wait
bless the man who did the camera work
cuz he spotted it as well he must have
been a very high level rank as well he
cut away from the handshake
to spare this man of the cringe and it
almost got away with it so I applaud
that good job you guys eSports has been
getting really big lately and a lot of
professional video game players are
actually getting pretty famous
here's a guy who goes by the name of
Seagal finishing up an interview at a
competition this week and check out his
cool handshake at the end watch thank
you wait why is Jimmy Fallon stealing my
idea Jimmy Fallon
don't make me challenge you don't make
me add you to the list of the nine year
olds enemies you know what I bet you
there's some cringe of you Jimmy first
of all this clip is amazing I feel bad
for Seagal though I'm sure he's laughing
at it in his grave because he's dead you
can't survive this quaint
if Jimmy Fallon is laughing at you that
that's not you let's say you know you
miss that that's deep
I guess video games help with a hand-eye
coordination but not hand hand
coordination good joke Jimmy who wrote
that for you Jimmy Fallon and shake
failed all right come on give me
something
all right well he's sweating he's got
pit stains so yeah
joke's on you where's this Indian know
it's time
Taiwanese shake look at this guy
instigator shake dance visual where is
it where is it
show me the French take me to the cringe
[Applause]
it's sometimes you just gotta throw your
hand out and see where it lands
and so how I touch boobs for the first
time all right moving on wait what is
this handshake fail Indigo Prophecy wait
it fails the handshake I failed the
handshake is the game over
hey games over not an even video games
kid hit look he died wait I play this
game did I that I failed the handshake
ah man
can someone please look that up it's
possible that I didn't even play this
part cuz there's a bunch of different
routes in the game right
oh man please like that yeah you go
forward we go side
[Music]
that's the thing if you may set up a
handshake new abilities unlock on you
this guy got so angry That's not me
editing that by the way yeah you go
forward we go side all right that's it
that's it that's it for the fresh
handshakes as always if you find them if
you find any cringe send it my way and I
will review it this has been hand shake
the screen right now if you enjoyed the
up